pas bien henri michel bonsoir que vous
êtes arrivé jeudi bonsoir comment ça va
en fait non ça va pas enfin pas du tout
d'être content mais pas content contre
vous propose aux joueurs il n'y ni
contrôle ni contre les joueurs je crois
que l'équipe de france à des titres
maintenant à un passé se doit d'être
présente dans la compétition et quand on
perd un match chez soi dans les
éliminatoires du championnat d'europe et
bien disons que les chances sont
compromises
maintenant il reste une petite il faudra
la jouer à fond
mais au delà de au delà du résultat
lui-même
c'est peut-être la manière qui nous qui
ne convient pas tout à fait ça fait 15
ans qu'on n'a pas perdu à paris c'est un
produit enfin que nous perdons pendant
une mi-temps nous avons réussi à
maintenir cette équipe société qui vous
l'avez souligné qu'il ya qui a filmé un
super le parti après bien ils nous
auraient pu user physiquement nous ont
plongés
disons que le résultat est tout à fait
logique oui très honnêtement entre nous
est-ce que vous avez le pouvoir l envie
de dire à certains joueurs c'est fini
une équipe de france je même parler des
grands nombres
est ce que vous pouvez dire vous à
michel platini et bien non je ne
sélectionne pas jamais gênent le pouvoir
si je mettrai le pouvoir entre
guillemets mais je crois et je tiens là
une inconnue et que j'ai toujours adopté
je pense que la meilleure le meilleur
moyenne de faire poursuivre cette
aventure qui dure depuis un bon moment
et des résultats exceptionnels qui a eu
ce groupe et cette équipe de france
depuis pas mal d'années c'est de
permettre des jeunes joueurs de
s'affirmer et de prendre confiance et de
d'acquérir une certaine expérience le
meilleur moyen de le faire c'est d'être
encadrés par des grands joueurs et de et
d'anciens qui eux en cette expérience là
et je pense qu'une chef de platini fait
partie de ces gens là alors
il était là pour ce match contre l'urss
nous avons un engagement oral tous les
deux pour une saison mais s'il est pas
en forme pour le prochain match contre
l'eire dr marc exempt eh bien ce sera
bon a décidé de savoir si je ne
sélectionne ou pas alors la dernière
question c'est si nous ne sommes pas si
l'équipe de france n'est pas qualifiée
pour le championnat d'europe en 88 vous
démissionnez non je me pose même pas la
question de ça le problème de savoir si
l'équipe de france va va continuer les
va se maintenir au plus haut niveau dans
la hiérarchie européenne ou mondiale ce
qui est exceptionnel pour un pays comme
la france au niveau football y en a on a
pataugé un peu pendant pas mal d'années
et puis on n'est pas venu à des normes
résultats alors je crois qu'il faut
essayer de continuer ça je crois qu'il
ya du travail qui est fait à tous les
niveaux que ce soit dans la masse que ce
soit ni modèle et vite
je crois qu'il faut il faut continuer
cette chose là et pour continuer bien il
est évident qu'il faut un renouvellement
de l'équipe mais on peut pas faire tirs
entre d'un seul coup sûr sur un groupe
sur une équipe sur des joueurs
c'est une au transit sur une transition
un peu idiot mais aussi je dirais
question en faisant michel j'ai entendu
des joueurs dire qu'ils s'étaient
peut-être un peu fatigué par un début de
championnat qui était beaucoup trop
beaucoup trop chargé alors est-ce que
vous avez le pouvoir je reprends
l'expression gérard hotte de modifier
quadrillé moins de club en première
division - de match c'est la question
qui est souvent posée que les clubs
posent que la fédération se pose que la
ligue nationale se pose c'est de savoir
comment on peut faire pour améliorer la
compétitivité que ça soit dans nos clubs
de notre équipe nationale pour que notre
football il ya deux du mieux possible je
pense et je le dis à midi aussi je crois
que si elle pouvait réduire le nombre de
clubs chez nous mais ça me paraît
extrêmement difficile qu'on a eu un
début de saison extrêmement chargé c'est
vrai il ya hier les hommes et chez trop
chargé mais les soviétiques aussi on
joue énormément de matches depuis la
coupe du monde et ils sont bien
comportées hier on a eu une semaine on a
donné des faveurs à l'équipe de france
aussi pour se préparer une semaine plus
tôt pour un nombre réduit de club en
première division
comment personnellement oui mais je sais
que ça fait pas plaisir à tout le monde
mais je pense qu'au côté sportif et pour
étalonner justement et se passer dès les
matchs tout au long de l'année
merci henri michel